have you guys heard about gender
disappointment this apparently is a type
of depression that kicks in when a
couple has a baby of a sex that they
didn't want the baby to have can be a
boy sometimes they're upset about that
can be a girl so we're not playing sides
here so couples have started actually
selecting the sex of the baby that
they're gonna have and we've got some
more info for you the process which can
only be conducted as part of in vitro
fertilization treatments screens embryos
to make sure they have the right number
of chromosomes and that they are free of
abnormalities that could signal
disorders such as Down syndrome and
trisomy 18 but PGS also reveals the sex
of an embryo with a nearly hundred
percent accuracy rate leading to an
explosion of perfectly fertile couples
opting for unnecessary IVF treatments
okay on its head I don't think this is
that bad this is what science does right
we keep advancing and we can choose
things about our bodies and hair color
eventually and eye color and all that
stuff I have two science people with me
thoughts I mean I don't really see a
problem with it I mean like I I actually
kind of like the idea that you can
screen for different genetic
abnormalities like Down syndrome or
Edwards syndrome it's just it's nice to
be able to see that kind of thing
because I think most women who do get
pregnant with a baby with Down syndrome
for example they end up having an
abortion at some point so it'd be better
to know that earlier than later right
and we've been doing this in terms of
diseases we've been doing this for a
long long time right screening for
diseases but is there a difference in
something that is a life-threatening to
screening for a life-threatening disease
as opposed to just the gender of what
would be a perfectly healthy child I
don't think so I mean where do you draw
that line and whose whose whose gets to
tell you that you have to draw that line
right so it's in the Bible somewhere
exactly that's the problem the people
are really pissed off about this are the
people that make the argument you're
playing God well I don't [ __ ] believe
in God so I don't really see a problem
you know I don't like how that quote
specifically said a bunch of people are
signing up now for unnecessary IVF
treatments like whose right is it to say
that it's unnecessary for parents to
want to know this and I mean the the
article specifically that that we were
looking at here focused on a woman who
had three boys and she was really sad
that she hadn't had a girl yet and she
wanted to make sure that she was going
to have a girl I have a different
problem
with that having more kids than you are
like I really agree that if you're going
to have children you should have
replacement numbers only replacement or
less because we have a massive
population issue and the fact that they
are doubling the size of their family
there is problematic for me I think that
it might actually prevent people from
having too many children if they can go
in you know a lot of people might say I
want one boy in one girl and then I'm
done but they keep having kids because
they're waiting for that girl so in a
way I think that this could be better
for the globe for the environment and
for our population numbers that people
can go in and make those kinds of
decisions early it's also going to
prevent like you said later stage
abortion so the right to life people
should be thrilled about that right now
what about I know there's gonna be
people who say well if you allow this to
happen well the next thing that's gonna
happen is they're gonna find the gay
gene and then they're gonna start
aborting gay babies
well no scientists I mean you need to
think on that what everybody that's
always go to that's an unscientific view
of science so there is no gay gene we
know that there are you know things that
are correlated genetically where
homosexuality but there is no gay gene
and no legitimate scientist or
practitioner would be willing to do some
sort of some sort of treatment or some
sort of procedure based on that because
it's not it's not founded on anything
legitimate like we know things founded
anything legitimate as I said people
another thing people are hysterical and
they make these these fear-based claims
about some future that's not defined and
about some future that's not founded on
science anybody within the scientific
community goes yeah that's not an issue
that's a non-starter like they're
[ __ ] worried about it like maybe if
you're worried about people choosing the
eye color their babies that's a real
thing people can do that now but like
who cares
a lot of people were commenting saying
that they didn't like this idea because
they felt like it was gonna mess with
our genetics in the future like he was
gonna somehow hurt us like evolution
make you know right it wasn't gonna work
out for us in the future something but
that just makes no sense to me because
if you're gonna go with the whole
natural selection route then you
wouldn't be treating people who have any
kind of disease right no you wouldn't
have you know things that would normally
you know that wouldn't be preventing
yeah it's also an unscientific argument
because this
embryo was still produced by combining
mother and father DNA to produce a child
we know that half of your genetic
complement comes from your mom half of
it comes from your dad and it mixes in
very random I way
randomized ways to produce you so if you
have a biological sibling they're very
grossly different from you because of a
different recombination of those genes
so whether you decide to to abort or or
end a pregnancy early and go with
another trial it's still a naturally
made baby I just don't understand why
going in looking at what's already
cooking and deciding whether or not it's
the combination that you want right it's
not really any doing so of course the
right to life people would of course say
that they believe life starts at
conception so that's why they in the
cooking process as you call it that's
why they'd be upset about it but I get I
obviously I get that totally it's like
wouldn't you rather get rid of a
single-celled organism or a small small
multicellular organism than a fully
fledged embryo to me it just seems like
a better way to to end a pregnancy early
yeah all right so I had a feeling we
were all gonna agree on the science on
this one but just do you think there's
an interesting socio-economic argument
because obviously this is going to be
expensive I think they said it was gonna
cost around 50 grand so only people with
that kind of money you're gonna be able
to do this so is there some danger in
that that only rich people will be able
to select I don't know exactly where I'm
going this it's a little brave new world
II yeah that's the only rich people will
be able to maybe for some reason only
rich people will want boys no there's
the danger it's not that only rich
people will be able to pick a boy or a
girl
it's that only rich people get to look
to find out early if they have a kid
with Down syndrome which is already an
issue at play there's a huge
socio-economic divide here and so what
you end up with is impoverished people
who potentially will get pregnant with
the child that they already can't afford
to raise and then they have to rely on
on governmental help on entitlement
programs things that I think should be
in place to help with people who are in
these situations but if they had access
earlier access to the types of tools
that rich people have access to you
wouldn't see a lifetime of medical
necessity and a lifetime of expense that
they can't afford to begin with it has
less to do with this designer baby
[ __ ] and so much more
with issues that are already on the
table so you could basically make the
argument that the reason we need to do
this now is that ultimately it will
eventually get cheaper and then everyone
including poorer people will be able to
do it and we can get rid of some of
those diseases right yeah I don't see a
problem with it yeah Jacqueline's down I
think we've I think we saw that one no
go no I'm just gonna say an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure we
all know this this is the same thing she
goes finishing strong